o ser humano é uma multiplicidade de
psicológico
nós temos diversos e os eus que muitas
vezes ficam brigando pela posse de um
território comum e que na verdade nos
boi cota nos fruta e nos fazem felizes
então é importantíssimo é fundamental
que nós façamos uma profunda análise de
nós mesmos de quem somos dos hells que
trazemos o que eles têm para nos dizer o
que temos para aprender com cada um
deles e promover essa unidade é que
sejamos seres íntegros verdadeiramente
integrais e possamos ajudar o outro
porque se nós tivermos em pedaços
nós não temos condições de olhar para o
outro como um ser único
o mundo como ser único
então eu estive presente há dois meses
atrás num evento de pedagogia
lá em alto paraíso sobre educação onde
estava presente pessoas de ongs do do
poder público de representantes de
grupos dos quilombolas dos indígenas
pretos brancos índios é alunos
professores e todos juntos fazendo a
discussão do que seria melhor a ao ser
humano
e juntos chegamos à conclusão que
chegamos todos de que devemos ser mais
humanos
é isso que falta
nós precisamos olhar para nós mesmos com
carinho com respeito com amor para que
possamos olhar para o outro nos enxergar
luz neles então todas as crenças que eu
carregava quando eu cheguei lá sobre
muitas coisas
ela se desfizeram hoje e eu tô no
processo numa caminhada no aprendizado
que nunca acaba
eu percebo que eu faço parte de cada uma
daquelas pessoas e aquelas pessoas fazem
parte de mim e uma das coisas que eu que
eu aprendi lá que foi mais linda foi o
sentido palavra gratidão gratidão é
quando a gente reverencia o criador ea
sua obra e lá ninguém fala obrigado
porque não somos obrigados quando
fazemos coração
nós falamos gratidão nós reverenciamos o
que o outro tem de divino de luz então
que eu trago para vocês hoje é pra vocês
buscarem essa unicidade dentro de vocês
para que juntos possamos ser uma
humanidade de verdade gratidão